the stars made it a plus one night at
the critics choice awards welcome to
entertainment tonight oh but for miss
halle berry it was also a reminder of
who run the world yes she accepted the
see her award and not only did we see
her hallie made sure everyone hurt her
too
halle how does it feel to get to see her
award fantastic
so to every little girl who feels unseen
and unheard this is our way of saying to
you
we love you and we see you and you
deserve every good thing in this world
hallie arrived color coordinated with
boyfriend van hunt rocking an icy
cropped dew reminiscent of her look as
storm in x-men why she says it's for all
her beautiful fans that have wanted my
short hair back hallie was honored for
breaking down gender barriers and her
fiery call for female empowerment almost
brought lady gaga to tears
what is this moment to be presenting
halle berry with the see her award you
know hallie is a legend she's an
inspiration
[Applause]
she paved the way for so many of us i'm
here because she's here so i love her
who else do the critics love will smith
who looks like he's on the road to oscar
for best actor the king richard starr
snagged a bafta in london and a critics
choice award in la where he walked the
carpet with wife jada pinkett smith this
is the guy i want to be in this business
you know introducing and shielding
actors coming into
[Music]
this world you know
while will was backstage in the press
room denzel washington kept jada and
venus williams company at their table
but earlier in the day will was with
another friend cbs news's gail king
talking about what happens behind closed
doors in his marriage you both have
talked very candidly infidelity in the
marriage and how you navigated that an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely there's never
been infidelity in our marriage never
been infidelium
never jada and i
talk about everything
and we have never surprised one another
with anything ever yes these two looked
rock solid on the red carpet and they
weren't the only couple calling it a
date night the one and only billy
crystal
billy crystal who turned 74 today gave a
sweet shout out to his wife as he
accepted the lifetime achievement award
my janice and i will be married 52 years
in june
and we produced this amazing life
together
belfast
jamie dornan held hands with wife amelia
warner on the carpet before accepting
for best acting ensemble you know we
have to ask you about this the story
everyone's loving this old roommate
situation you and andrew and robert
pattinson just told us that he would
always get the pity invite from you guys
i would say always invited as an
afterthought he sort of had success
earlier we're a bit like
does he really fit in with us because
we're not working
jamie's pal andrew garfield was solo
last night after he and girlfriend
alyssa miller made their red carpet
debut at the sag awards last month
jason here tonight is it a date night i
didn't get a plus one
i know
even for jason brenner melanie linsky
luckily jason met up with melanie at the
after party to celebrate her win for
best actress in a drama series my
husband jason the love of my life
but who simply stole our hearts hands
down joshua jackson and jody turner
smith they giggled on the red carpet and
kissed inside and with just 11 episodes
to go before their series finale the
stars of this is us are savoring every
moment are you two wearing the same suit
oh you know we
tag team this thing right
we're trying to have a yeah we're trying
to have a moment a twin moment
look i know it's an emotional time for
you guys it's all wrapping up we're
getting the kevin episode right what can
we expect
you see it all come to a head and you
which way is it gonna go have you guys
fully rap no we go until may you gonna
cry i'm not a massive crier but if if
there was ever a time that i would be uh
in tears it might be it might be that
yeah
does it feel good to be out are we doing
a date night tonight are we yeah my
husband's here i'm really excited it is
the mom and dad are out on the town by
the way how is baby are we hitting
milestones baby's a year now and he's
the best starting to walk talk do all
the things it's about to get real rowdy
chrissy metz co-wrote next week's this
is us episode which her tv mom directed
it's a massive episode for kate and toby
she's really coming into her own and to
be directed by mandy the cherry on top
of the icing on top of the cake
and could chrissy also be manifesting a
collab with melissa mccarthy did i just
see you on melissa
um yeah i'm trying to make her my friend
oh melissa christie's trying to make her
a friend yeah yeah
we've got a thing going on the nine
perfect strangers nominee just wrapped
production playing ursula on the
live-action remake of the little mermaid
poor unfortunate souls doing little
mermaid it was an out of body experience
i loved it and i cried like a baby on my
last day
house of gucci nominee jared leto will
transform once again in his new marvel
film morbius out april 1st
it's a brand new character so i'm super
excited to to share that with audiences
morbius originated as a spiderman
villain so that begs the question can we
expect a spiderman cameo well i tell you
i would love to get in the ring with
spiderman i think tom holland is amazing
and
we'd make quite a dynamic duo another
star into a cameo kristen shanowith
she's mentoring ariana grande in the big
screen adaptation of wicked haven't been
asked but you never know i think i'd be
great on the yellow brick road somewhere
i've known ariana grande since she was
10. we talk every day i love you baby
girl and it's an honor and a pleasure to
pass the wand and the crown to you and
mayam bialik knows what it's like to
carry a legacy on jeopardy welcome back
to jeopardy could we see you permanently
host um i would love that
miam says she has support from alex
trebek's family yeah i got to meet them
when we dedicated the stage they feel
what we're doing is supporting that
legacy
plus snl first-time nominee bowen yang
told me how that cast is supporting pete
davidson in the midst of his drama with
kanye we're just supporting him by just
giving him space i think i think he's
just figuring it out because i think a
lot is out of his control maybe we're
all thinking about him and we love him
so much
lady gaga gave us double the style drama
in london first up this emerald green
ralph lauren dress at the baftas it took
over 150 hours to make by hand and has
50 meters of velvet and taffeta wowza
then gaga turned up the heat at the
critics choice awards in this dare to
bear black and gold gucci gown come on
gaga i mean i love the gold so much i'm
channeling gaga today but from bold
color to skin bearing silhouettes this
critic's choice red carpet glamour was
brought to us on a global scale
it's um
i don't know
it was just flowy
just flowy
how do you sit down in that i don't know
let's figure it out inside
i'm not gonna lie i was feeling very
sleepy so i was like i'm just gonna do a
little shot to wake up and it worked
shot up shout out vodka
[Music]
i was eating meatballs from italy about
10 minutes ago that's the secret selena
gomez's secret she snacked on onion
rings before slipping into this sleek
louis vuitton gown yes the stars had us
seeing red on the carpet another trend
sparkles
kristen stewart in dolce and gabbana
coordinated with her fiance dylan meyer
sisters venus and serena williams both
wore versace and juno temple turned her
armani two-piece into a crop
the secret is i had a five-inch heel
and then i switched and i was like i
shall not
it's the smartest thing i've ever
done covid made me be like never a dress
ever again i was like if it's not
sweatpants i'm gonna do this i mean if i
could have worn sneakers i would have
but my stylist drew the line there
[Music]
winner hannah waddingham turned heads in
kiwi green carolina herrera while jean
smart made history in valentino as only
the fifth actress to sweep all five
major tv awards in a single season to
make the dress look good i was told if i
held it
watch this
[Music]
my lash almost fell loose
well those are the dilemmas that we
people face og west side story star rita
moreno was up against newbie ariana
dubose who stunned in yellow and gave
rita a sweet shout out when she won for
best supporting actress you made space
for me to
to thrive beside you and that's the
greatest gift you could have ever given
me name a cuter critics choice pair then
meet hotties alan kim and belfast jude
hill i'll wait oh wait there's not one
jude took home the best young actor
award much to his surprise i'm gonna
have to be completely honest i had
nothing prepared the 11 year old got
some love from his big screen dad jamie
dornan and a handshake from will smith
but can we go back to allen oh gosh he
was so sharp in a red dolce and gabon
i mean he looked amazing the
nine-year-old who was back to present
cracked this joke about his emotional
win from last year
it's crazy to look at a video of a
younger me
i was so emotional and inexperienced
well the old pro definitely kept it cool
when he got to meet the cast of squid
game we heard alan kim is here and he
really wants to meet you can we make
that
happen alan are you excited yes
you love do you love squid game
i've never watched it
of course he's not old enough to watch
squid games no he's not but that's all
the last i needed on a monday y'all we
love you alan you are so cute
[Music]